hello everyone
I've
just tested negative
for covid-19 after isolating for five
days
[Applause]
thankfully I'll not be able to return to
work in person but I I want to thank you
all for your well wishes your prayers
over this past week and the calls I've
gotten I also want to thank the medical
team here at the White House for the
incredible care they gave me fortunately
God thankfully thank God willing there
was my symptoms were mild my recovery
was quick and I'm feeling great
the entire time I was in isolation I was
able to work to carry out the duties of
the office and without any Interruption
it's a it's a real statement on where we
are in the fight against covet 19. right
now
we're we are facing a new variant the
ba-5 variant a very transmissible
version of open Crown variant we saw
here this past winter in fact this new
variant that infected me is getting a
lot of people infected all around the
world not just here in the United States
we should take precautions to try to
slow the spread of this virus
my Administration has made billions of
dollars in funding available to improve
ventilation in our schools and our
public buildings we may test widely
available so you can take one before
attending a large indoor Gatherings or
visiting with high-risk individuals
we've made high quality masks available
for free so you should consider wearing
a mask when you're in a crowded indoor
public place
these precautions add an extra layer of
protection for you and for those around
you
but the reality is that
ba5 means many of us are still going to
get covered even if we take the
precautions that doesn't mean we are
we're doing anything wrong unfortunately
this covet is still with us as it has
been for two and a half years but our
fight against covet is making a huge
difference
what's different now is our ability to
protect ourselves from serious illness
due to covet in fact that's radically
different today than it was just a year
ago
covet isn't gone but even with cases
climbing in this country covet deaths
are down nearly 90 percent
and when I took office that's 90 percent
difference for today and when I took
office
that's what's new that's what's new in
covert response different from where we
were just a year ago
even if covert even if you get covered
you can avoid winding up in a with a
severe case
you can now prevent most covet deaths
and that's because three free tools my
Administration has invested in and
distributed this past year booster shots
at home tests easy to use effective
treatments
we've got through covert with no fear I
got through with no fear a very mild
discomfort because of these Essentials
life-saving tools
and guess what I want to remind
everybody they are free they are
convenient and they are safe
and they work